always appointment viewing when you can
watch the eight-time all-star and
three-time cy young award winner clayton
kershaw on the mound his place in
baseball history is secure
the o2 conference strikes out swinging
so kershaw's off to a good start on the
year
kershaw in 94 innings has struck out now
112 walking only 17.
all right
had to throw him four strikes to strike
him out
a pair of punch outs and a one two three
start to the ball game
advert also lie on the mound for chicago
tonight 26 year old still rookie right
hander four wins and six losses he's got
a heavy two cena
a one-no pitch from mookie betts out to
center field mariznick was fooled a
little bit by the sunshine but ends up
making the catch
and on a one-two pitch a comebacker for
al zalad that'll turn into an easy
inning ending double play
nothing despite the one-out walk clayton
kershaw back to work and a scoreless
start to the night
still owen two
doubled up on the slider back foot got
him that is classic clayton kershaw
[Applause]
oh it could be one of those days for
clayton kershaw
bases loaded with nobody out and a huge
opportunity for zach mckinstry early in
the ball game
1-1
mckinsley swings and sends it ball to
deep right field peterson back and it's
gone
rookie versus rookie and the hitter wins
a grand slam for zach mckinstry
four-nothing dodgers two balls and no
strikes to bellinger the eighth dodger
to bat in the inning
[Applause]
high drive out to right field
peterson backing up feeling for the wall
and that one's gone
the walk-off
yesterday a two-run shot here in the
second and the dodgers have a half a
dozen on the board it is six to nothing
[Applause]
two balls and two strikes to eric sogart
patrick wisdom aboard on the lead off
base hit first base runner against
kershaw but that's his fifth strikeout
of the night already
no balls two strikes
ball strike three inside corner six
strikeouts for kershaw
two out
curveball got him
that'll make dave roberts smile
a pitch the dodger manager has been
lobbying for increased usage by the
eight-time all-star
[Music]
gets a call on a pitch that missed the
plate
he likes this match-up for sure
[Applause]
a couple of curveballs here late from
kershawn he strikes out bryant with the
slider
eight strikeouts for kershaw two outs
here's baez the cubs cleanup hitter
mojave has just got him off the end of
the bat still strong enough to take
kershaw opposite field by his 18th of
the year and the cubs are around the
board in the fourth
small victory for chicago to score with
two out in the inning they're going to
have to settle with the one however as
kershaw's out of any further trouble
nance on three and two and betts strikes
out swinging
tommy nance bid for a one two three
inning comes to an end as justin turner
sends one into right center field turner
heading into second with a two out
double
big curveball strikes out patrick wisdom
10
for clayton kershaw
good morning good afternoon good night
and clayton kershaw has tied a season
high with 11 strikeouts tonight
1-1 to chris taylor
chopper to third nice bare-handed pick
by sogar
and soka with a bare hand
gets down measures it and then throws
across his body and nice pickup for
wisdom on the back end
taking a base hit away from taylor
the dodgers are challenging the call at
first base
wisdom on the receiving end oh boy it
looks like the dodgers are going to win
that one too
despite the great play by sogar good
play by wisdom on the receiving end as
well
yeah i think he beat it out
balls overturn
and lux is safe on an infield single
taylor is safe rather on an infield
single
couple of really good breaking balls
from tommy nan strikeout mckinstry there
are two away
and the 3-2 curveball locks up barnes no
damage despite the single the wild pitch
in the stolen base still 6-1 la
doing that at the age of 33 in his 14th
season and that slider has been filthy
tonight
12 for the three-time cy young award
winner
0-1 pitch to mookie betts out to right
field
bryant lays out and it's past him
betts thinking about three
throw to third not even close
infield comes in play a shift on for
bellinger
bellinger sends a high fly ball out to
right that's going to be more than
enough to tag and score bets
7-1 los angeles on bellinger's third rbi
of the night
a chopper turner makes the play at
second and gets the throw to first in
time to double off peterson
[Applause]
roberts made it all the way home on a
ground ball just inside the third base
match
against the cubs in 2003
as wisdom strikes out the 13th strikeout
victim for kershaw and the first out of
the eighth most strikeouts since july 9
2017 against kansas city clayton kershaw
going over the 100 pitch mark for the
fourth time in his 17 starts this year
and on pitch 101 a ground ball that will
retire the side
13 strikeouts for clayton kershaw
tonight 12 via the breaking ball that's
the most by any starter on a breaking
ball this year he has been phenomenal
this evening in eight innings of work is
all about number 22 tonight
three in a row for los angeles